[Music]
what's up Wolfgang
I just don't know tap on something that
is very exciting I stumbled upon a new
infinity war trailer and I know I just
released one earlier today but I have
never seen this one before I haven't
seen it from Marvel I haven't seen on
YouTube
I can't find it I'm sure it's out there
somewhere and if it is let me know but
it has new scenes that I've never seen
before so I wanted to show them to you
please be sure to subscribe to my
channel and join the wolf gang to stay
up-to-date on Avengers freakin infinity
war only he didn't use frickin one April
27th where will you be
when it all lands Avengers infinity war
with a pg-13 okay first new scene dr.
strange working some magic this looks
like the beginning of a scene that we
saw in a different new trailer a few
days ago I believe that this scene is
Doctor Strange trying to trap Thanos and
some sort of magical force barrier if
you look at these orange laser type of
lightning ish things you can see them in
this other trailer as well so I believe
that this is on Titan and it's a fight
between Thanos and Doctor Strange this
next scene is of good ol Spidey and I
think it's kind of self-explanatory
one of thanasis ships comes to New York
in which spider-man jumps on it then the
ship leaves and heads out of the Earth's
atmosphere as you can see here
spider-man does not have his iron spider
suit yet he has his old suit so he
cannot breathe outside of the Earth's
atmosphere as you can see he runs out of
breath here his eyes roll into the back
of his head and he falls but don't worry
we know from the other trailers that
Iron Man is right behind him and saves
him this scene was star-lord although it
is very brief it seems very important
you can tell that he is just super
freaked out and scared I mentioned this
in the video I did earlier today where I
on man is holding back star-lord I think
that Thanos has kidnapped Gamora and
takes her away or perhaps one of the
guardians of the galaxy died we'll only
know by seeing the movie when it comes
out in 15 days this last scene which I
think is just amazing is of Thanos using
his Infinity Gauntlet
specifically the Power Stone in the
Infinity Gauntlet as I mentioned before
we've seen the first part of this scene
in a previous trailer that was released
but we didn't see thinness using the
Power Stone again what I think is
happening here is that dr. strange is
using his magic to try to trap Thanos
into some sort of force barrier then
Thanos breaks out and attacks one of the
Avengers most likely dr. strange with
the Power Stone this is really awesome
because it's one of the first times that
we've actually seen daños using the
power of the Infinity stones well that's
it for the trailer it's short and sweet
and again I'm sure it's up there
somewhere but I've never seen it before
and I wanted to make
you all got the chance to see it
yourself be sure to LIKE this video and
please subscribe to my channel to stay
up to date on Avengers infinity war I
promise to always do my best to bring
you things like this video look out I
try gosh thank you so much for watching
woof woof